Yeah. I don't know what to say, but just tell me what song you like better,
never too much, or a house, not a home from Luther Vandross.
Mike is black. Mike is black without seeing someone.
How can you tell if they are black and white,
when you ain't black through their name,
through their knowledge of black television shows,
black movies and black culture, is it their voice?
We brought together six black people and one secret white person with no
cameras. Can they find the odd man out?
My questions would be experiential, but one sticker,
white person will probably be a white person who knows R and
B. Who knows the class.
You got to want to learn. I'm going to figure it out
is telling a fib just based off of how they're communicating with us.
Hopefully that works. It might not work today.
I'm just going to be asking like mostly,
very popular black pop culture questions. I'm just going to be,
to look for like a little generic stereotypes. And most people associate,
because I feel like the mold is going to try to play some, you know, black,
stereotypical things. I'm just gonna start calling people out. Hey everyone.
My name is James Jessica, and my pronouns. Are he him? His I'm super,
super excited to be here,
but also obviously very nervous and not really planning on using this strategy.
I'm just going to be me. Um,
I just have like a inappropriate profile picture at the moment.
This moment that he knew he.
Oh God, Oh, camera's black. I would say that.
Really quickly. We can't figure out where the mall is.
Where we're all from. Someone's from San Francisco.
I can't tell him, you know,
I like Karen. Alrighty. Okay.
The conversation is going to lowland. Come on, guys.
They asked about black is King. I see. I don't have that.
Where are everyone's period?
No, I didn't do that. We're going to ask you this. I shouldn't watch a movie,
but see, I don't have a district money.
Parents from the parents from.
Black is King. I honestly don't know what black is. Black is.
Wait a second.
Cami. So she started Jamaica.
I'll be really mad if they're lying about being from Navy.
People from Dubai, do they consider themselves? But Karen's thinking now,
Karen don't do this to me. That I were to say,
my parents are from Ireland and Poland and it's, it's, it's a, it's an obvious,
um,
the layers of blackness genes. And that is time.
That round one round.
One was tough. Oh my God. That was so hard on this round.
I felt kind of okay. Um, I was just trying to be super casual with it.
I think we were all just kinda chatting.
It didn't feel like anyone was like aiming Porsche in person or camera
cameras. I'm gonna say James.
I think I'm going to vote Micah. Okay.
I'm going with Micah because everyone else changed their mojo to black.
Thinking about Cameron. Cameron.
I don't know. Kevin sounds like a white name, so I'm just going to vote.
Cameron and Cameron has to go. The person eliminated.
This round is Cameron.
Oh God. See? Okay. The game moves too fast. People don't think as fast as I do.
That's probably why I'm out.
How old is everyone? Oh, 21 years old at 19.
I have a question in there.
Forever. Why are you in Dubai? Full-time student.
Yo wait, Trevor. James is compensated. He be saying yo too much.
I have experienced racism. Jeans. He got every time you experienced racism.
Oh.
Oh, he said no BS. Let's go.
Obviously, no one finished. I mean like I don't really get fetishized. Um,
but it me off.
I love being called articulate a question.
I can relate to that. That not a given.
Well, mine was runway skinny solo shop.
I did not.
Who didn't answer.
Mike has talked about being articulate charter service, Jeremy.
Some best often shot called him the N word and love.
[Inaudible] just hit Netflix.
[Inaudible] this scrubbers.
Someone said her hair felt like this scrub.
Living single apps.
Oh. Oh. I thought I thought they read like living like,
cause I'm single currently. Nope. Um,
to be honest and not the biggest sit-com.
Teammates. James, I don't know.
James you're on my list.
How do y'all feel about princess and the frog?
How do you type and talk and process so much
stuff here? A couple of years, buddy. Now, LeBron James,
not LeBron James.
I get what Disney was trying to do.
I'm really happy about it.
I'm mad. Cause she was a frog, never Disneyland.
So I know what you're talking about.
Stop making characters into now.
Why is our.
One movie, us being an amphibian?
What are we even talking about? And that is time.
I don't want to drink it. So I'm going to I'll come in. Um,
I'm feeling a little more calm.
James. When I mentioned, uh, nineties black TV shows,
he said he's not made into sitcoms.
I haven't met a black person who didn't watch, you know,
sitcoms. So I'm going to vote for Trevor James prompt.
In this round. I think I'm most suspicious of James.
I guess I'm going to have to go with Trevor.
Forever. I'm going to go with Trevor
and I don't even know why.
This round there is actually a tie. Oh my God.
We love a good tie over here. So here we go. The tie is between
Trevor and Jane.
So what this means is you will now vote again between those two people,
Which is in Trevor.
Cause I chose him last time I voted for Trevor because I don't want to be out.
I know it's man and no issue. You're the one coming from me. I'm going to stick.
With G. I'm.
Not convinced that it's strawberry.
On the other hand, we're going to go James. Sorry. I'm changing it up.
I feel like Trevor wouldn't lie about someone calling him the N word and leaving.
The person eliminated this round is.
Obviously like I'm a little I'm upset.
I w I want to personally know why, what gave it away per se?
I mean like obviously, maybe like a ton of things did.
The first time
I brought out to the woods.
For me.
Whenever.
My mom was holding or.
Jeez. All right, Brandon. Definitely.
My favorite line is it hurts you
more than it hurts. My son, my favorite line is ever.
It hurts you more than it hurts me.
It hurts me more than it hurts. No, it does. It really knows it. I don't know.
They're typing so fast.
It's a secret. My person is still in here.
They're guilty of digital black things.
That is Oh, to say, okay, Brandon, Brandon is fine.
I'm still going with Trevor bro. There is no.
And that's all facts. No, one's calling me.
How do you, Oh, how do you feel about white people in braids?
Ooh, like honestly,
Kim Kardashians did not do it first.
Oh, The most BS. Excuse.
Uh, wait his shoppers thing. Sorry.
Smart thing would be to vote for Trevor.
Well, I'm going to just touch ya. Sorry girl.
I think the person I'm going to go for is Trevor.
I think we're all black in here. I know Brandon's off the mall.
I don't think Cassie has the mall. I don't think Cammie's the mall.
Which leaves rubber.
The person eliminated this round is Trevor.
It's soft to be eliminated.
I really thought that I was able to like try and show that I have experienced
the black experience and the black experience.
I couldn't really talk and things like boxer briefs and stuff like that.
I don't know. Oxfords. I've never braided my hair.
Give me a thumbs up. If you want to continue the game or thumbs down.
If you think that you already caught them all.
Alright so we will continue.
What would you even say?
I'm ready? My name is Brandon.
I was actually in another jewelry video in the sixth stomach crosses one secret
or poker video.
And I was a guy who said I'm black and I'm off to still black right now. Yeah.
I don't know what to say, but just tell me you fall. You like better?
Never too much. Or how it's not a [inaudible].
Mike.
How are you guys? I'm Katsuya. I'll speak a little Creole.
So you know I'm black.
Vote me out. Hello? Hello?
Hello? Uh, Cami's here. Um, let me speak Luca.
I don't know what else to say.
I screwed up voting thinking. Micah might not have been a black person.
I think we're all black at this point.
Oh, what did I do? I said, let's talk about Luther Vandross. Why?
And I hope y'all feel dumb.
I hope y'all feel dumb because none of us were in the mall from the boys alone.
I'm more suspicious of Micah. I was so
sure about,
and she has a yellow hand emoji, like why not use the black?
You know,
if I'm wrong.
I'm a vote for Micah. Just because that's the person I was suspicious of.
I'm sorry, Micah.
I'm voting for Brandon simply because he was the first one to
put the thumbs up.
The person eliminated this round is Mike.
I was really kicked out, honestly,
though, like I'm not even mad at them. Like I sounded stupid.
If the color.
Turns green, you have won the game.
The color turns red.
The mole is still in the game and you lose three,
two, one.
Beautiful.
You can reveal yourself three, two, one. Oh,
I'm so sorry.
I knew I want them all. I knew y'all went to the mall, but then y'all
just respect me. Like if I was a mole, I would have a black lives matter.
Your life matters to James James. He doesn't watch.
Yeah. Yeah.
He could have saved yourself the same watch,
fresh Prince of Bel air or something like that.
The fact that I was this close and all,
because I couldn't find the thumbs up. I really like all of the Iowa.
We just want to be all their friends. To be honest, I wanted to learn.
I want it to be educated. I think it's important to, um, you know,
as white people to continue educating,
not by going to people and being like educating,
but like doing your own research and whatnot I learned from this experience is
that there's not a set way or a certain way on how to be black because
blackness is much more than just what meets the eye. Of course,
we're all going to have our individual experiences.
But I think when you tap into those things that bring us together while also
find your individuality, I think that's the most important part of blackness.